miss Douglas owlsley during the sour
40-minute event you'll learn about the
scientists career and then hear from mr.
Alice Lee himself as a recount as work
on the Branch Davidians
and Kennewick Man so my pleasure to
welcome you to the National Museum of
Natural History I'm Randall Kramer
director of public affairs and I'm going
to be in the distinct enviable position
of opening tonight's program with author
Jeff Benedict and forensic
anthropologist dr. Doug Owsley it's also
my pleasure to welcome you to spring and
I assure you that our technical people
are doing everything they can to get the
air conditioning turned on and to make
this a little bit cooler inside first of
all I'd like to acknowledge the presence
this evening of the Smithsonian's
undersecretary for science dr. David
Evans dr. Evans is essentially in charge
of all science at the Smithsonian and we
also have with us this evening the new
director for the National Museum of
Natural History dr. Christensen poor dr.
stem poor recently joined us and it's
certainly our pleasure to have dr. Evans
and dr. Sam pore with us this evening
the study of forensic anthropology has
its modern roots right here at the
Smithsonian in addition to having the
largest physical anthropology collection
in the world
the Smithsonian is also recognized for
the preeminence of its forensic
anthropology scientists it's a team that
in addition to dr. Doug Owsley includes
dr. Douglas you blocker dr. Dave hunt
and Kerry Brule Hyde with his colleagues
dr. Owsley uses his remarkable knowledge
of skeletal remains to assist law
enforcement officials throughout the
world in solving crimes in many cases
instances where criminal activity
occurred tens if not hundreds of years
prior dr. oz was equally involved in
discovering the truth about our own
origins the lives of our ancestors in
particular the first humans to inhabit
North America one of the most famous of
these investigations is that of
Kennewick Man a case that along with
others is the subject and is recounted
in detail in the new HarperCollins book
no bone unturned written by Jeff
Benedict the book provides a
behind-the-scenes window into
contemporary forensic anthropology
it's an exciting read and mr. Benedict
is well suited to take on this subject
is an award-winning investigative
journalist with many books and articles
to his credit his training as a lawyer
has proven invaluable in addressing the
legal issues surrounding many of the
cases but what makes these stories
ultimately so compelling so exciting is
the extraordinary life and the work of
Smithsonian's own dr. Doug Owsley the
dedication and humanity that he brings
to his work as inspiring as he is
relentless in the pursuit of truth is
also a friend of colleague of all of us
and he constantly amazes us with his
talent his love for his wife and family
who are with us this evening and the
affection with which he regards the
human race our program will begin then
with Jeff Benedict and then follow with
the presentation by dr. Alice Lee and
after that we will be delighted to open
the floor to questions Jeff
good evening everyone it's a true
pleasure and honor to be here in this
wonderful institution which has become a
second home to me as a journalist over
the last three years it truly is a great
opportunity to be here tonight in the
midst of many great scientists and
people who work at this institution to
preserve our history and teach us I want
to begin with a model that I have as a
journalist an investigative journalist
which is a specific kind of journalist
and the motto is that an investigative
journalists role is to shine light in
dark places and typically I have been
involved in doing books that uncover
things typically scandalous things that
have legal and political implications a
couple years ago I got interested in a
discovery that occurred in 1996 on the
banks of the Columbia River in the
corner of Washington near the Oregon
border two young boys attending a public
boat race on a summer afternoon we're
waiting in knee-deep water and stumbled
across something hard on the bed of the
river bed they learned down and picked
it up and it turned out it was a human
skull they summoned the police police
looked at it brought in a corner and
there was a determination that this guy
looked pretty old probably too old to be
a recent homicide victim but to be sure
they brought in a forensic
anthropologist who had a contract with
the coroner's office he examined it and
concurred that this was old and
something that needed more study he also
was intrigued because of how close it
was to the place where Lewis and Clark
had camped a couple weeks later after
sending this a specimen of this bone to
an age dating facility in California it
was determined that this skull and a
myriad of other bones that were
recovered with it were roughly 9600
years old where I got interested in this
case was in the events that followed
when the Army Corps of Engineers seized
it and indicated publicly that there
would not be any study of the
Jermaine's a lawsuit was filed and I
decided to possibly write a book about
it I went out to Portland and to Seattle
in that area and did a bunch of
interviews and research and just as I
was about to leave to go home to start
writing a book proposal one of the
lawyers that represented the scientists
in this case said almost in passing you
ought to get to know our clients they're
very interesting men I was exhausted and
almost didn't bother asking but couldn't
resist what's so interesting about that
and the one person that this lawyer
talked about was Doug Owsley a name that
quite frankly meant nothing to me
at that stage of my research I'd never
heard it before I said tell me about him
and she said well what I can tell you is
that he does a lot of work for the
government
aside from studying ancient skeletons he
went to Waco and helped with the
identification and sorting of the
victims in the Waco Fire
he went to Guatemala and helped solved
an unsolved murder of two American
journalists that had died there during
the first Bush administration he was
given permission to go there and solve
the mystery they covered the front page
of the New York Times he helped identify
pilots from the first Persian Gulf War
and she started to list case after case
and I who consider myself somewhat
well-read thought sounds like the most
famous person I've never heard of and I
asked for permission to talk to him and
she gave it to me and I called him and I
came here three years ago for the first
time to meet Doug in his office I
brought my young son and my wife and we
walked in and I had a tape recorder with
me which I turned on from the minute we
met and I asked Doug about things I saw
in his office boxes with skeletons
things on the tables and at one point
early on he said I work in different
kinds of worlds and those seven words
I've never forgotten there in the
prologue to my book and they were a
turning point for me as a journalist and
this was a major turn to go from writing
a book about it lawsuit to writing a
book about a forensic anthropologist
birds that had I been tested I could not
have adequately defined three years ago
and I decided to change the entire focus
of my book to focus on a man who works
in this institution who does things that
I thought were worthy of an entire book
treatment this institution is partly in
the business of recovering restoring and
preserving national treasures and I felt
like I had found a national treasure in
the archive of national treasures buried
in the bowels of these buildings someone
whose name most people would never know
but who was doing extraordinary things
I'm gonna do something in closing that I
wasn't intending to do but Randall
Kramer gave me an idea my best way to
introduce Doug is to give you a snippet
of something I wrote about him and I
think it's a sense of the kind of work
he does and why I was so fascinated with
him this is a scene from my book that
involves Doug and some of his colleagues
from this facility it took place in Waco
within weeks after the fire was over and
Doug's job with his colleagues was to go
there and help the FBI and the Tarrant
County officers with sorting the remains
of those people who were in the Waco
fire so that they could be properly
identified and I pick up in the middle
of this scene after days of sorting and
matching in the commingled bodies
owlsley had reconstructed the bodies of
nearly two dozen women and children with
the aid of videotapes of the children
taken shortly after the fire erupted
owlsley's assistants stone and sandesh
were able to match more than 100
tattered clothing articles from shoes to
diapers to hair barrettes with the
reconstructed children limbs missing and
vital organs charred by fire and
mutilated by shrapnel the children in
their clothing articles lined Gurney's
ready to be inventoried by Owsley in
preparation for autopsies an
identification number had been assigned
to each victim with stone at his side on
a laptop Osley lowered his white medical
mask over his nose and began with MC for
7c the smallest victim recovered from
the Waco compound arranged on a white
linen sheet MC for seven
he stood out as the only victim without
any recovered clothing items or
remaining flesh with a metal ruler
owlsley measured one of the femurs
barely over one inch in length based on
the measurements of the long bone
diathesis this fetus is about the 4th
month as we said placing the tiny femur
back on the gurney the fetal remains
include the frontal right humerus radius
and oma left and right in a minutes left
and right femur and left tibia the fetus
had been recovered with a 24-year old
female MC 47 whose long brown hair was
found twisted around the fingers of
another child
MC 47 be recovered next to her
measurements of the radius and ulna
suggest that the age of the child is
approximately three and a half years he
said moving to the next gurney owlsley
stood in front of a body identified as
MC 73 age 1.5 he said body is an
advanced stage of decomposition a foot
found in a stocking was separate from
the rest of the body the infant is
wearing a snap cotton undershirt and
diapers saturated in urine
now crystallized the waistband of the
diaper is decorated in Disney characters
the child's pants are ankle length
thermal underwear with the brand name
young stars
Doug stop stone said struggling to type
fast enough to keep up tell me when you
read it he said okay an extra pair of
pull-up diapers was associated with his
child he continued the child was female
the senseless killing of children
angered owlsley the only way he knew how
to keep his emotions in check was to
keep working shuffling his feet a few
inches he moved to victim MC 74 without
pausing quote this is a 78 and a half
year old child he said the child is
wearing dark cotton long underwear pants
with his index finger Osley cleaned off
the clothing label the brand name is st.
Michael he said maroon socks with
Rocketship's gold stars and the words
liftoff embroidered on them black and
purple tennis shoes with a basketball on
them he flipped the shoes over and the
name Patrick Ewing is inscribed on the
sole the next viscom was a child less
than two years old the diaper is filled
with fecal material owlsley observed
stones stopped typing every diaper we've
seen is dirty she said which means every
kid was scared scared shitless quite
literally it's a natural human response
when you're scared as we said practic
whispering and there's no doubt these
kids were an awful fear Doug Owsley
well I'm very flattered that what I do
is of such interest I'm honored to have
a book written about me about my
research especially while I'm alive to
read it the daughter of a friend of our
family upon hearing that a book was
written about me said Doug Owsley why
would anybody want to write a book about
Doug Owsley she was a student at the
College of William and Mary right now
and I think she was very surprised one
day when her professor spent time in
class talking about my work but all in
all it is very difficult to live up to
the kind things that Jeff and Randall
have said I think I am a very ordinary
guy but that I have an interesting day
job that also happens to consume a lot
of my nights in planning for this
evening I asked my wife to attend she
keeps me grounded her comment was that
maybe she should read the book first but
likely that she's been there and done
that and she liked the book she has read
it and I'm very pleased that she came
she's very important to me my oldest
daughter was billeting us not long ago
and she's the lovely young lady that's
right next to my wife and I asked her if
she'd like a copy of the book and her
comment was well gee dad if you feel
like you need to give a copy to somebody
all Tapley and Hillary I'm pleased that
you're here - jeff has spent three years
researching and writing this book Jeff
is an investigative journalist with a
legal background he's a very skilled
writer that's interested in the facts
details and accuracy he became
interested in a very rare landmark case
one that one of those cases of a century
that explores the bonds interconnecting
science government policy religion and
the American public's right to
information I am glad that my work as a
scientist contributed to his creative
process some sections of his book deal
with my work as a Smithsonian forensic
scientist dealing with contemporary
medical legal investigations it is the
applied aspect of my work
this is part of a tradition of service
at the Smithsonian Smithsonian
scientists have ruined routinely worked
with law enforcement agencies in the
identification of human skeletal remains
they have done so since 1910 this work
takes time and there are very good
reasons why we do it for one thing we
look at it as public service in the
sense that it helps a family to to know
what happened to a loved one it won't
bring that person back but it can help
give closure and in a homicide you might
actually help figure out who did it and
keep it from happening to somebody else
in the same sense forensic cases are a
way that we gain experience and develop
our skills it's a feedback process in
the sense that we are constantly
conducting research on forensic problems
and when we identify someone and say I
think this person is able a white male
30 to 35 years as we get the positive
identification we learn from that and we
see where we are correct and where we
make our mistakes and we improve and in
the same sense it's a part of our
training in the sense that I deal with
predock's and postdocs and graduate
students all the time and we involve
them in our cases in the sense that is
experience gained on actual cases this
is how I was trained and it's how I
train the next generation other sections
in this book cover my research as a
scientist studying historic period
remains from the colonial sites of
Jamestown and st. Mary City and then
back thousands of years to ancient
remains that represent some of the first
Americans in the new world from studying
the few ancient remains that have been
discovered I became fascinated by them
the unanswered questions about the
peopling of the new world the peopling
of north america this background has
compelled me to become involved in the
Kennewick discovery which began actually
as a forensic case in the sense that I
was contacted by the local coroner's
office and asked to assist in the
examination analysis of some very
unusual human remains that have been
found along the bank of the Columbia
River in the state of Washington this
inquiry ultimately led to a lawsuit
against the Corps of Engineers in the
federal government it was something that
I became involved in in my private
capacity and not as a representative of
the Smithsonian Institution rightly or
wrongly I've always viewed myself as a
antis first and a Smithsonian scientist
second and I appreciate the fact that
the director of the National Museum of
Natural History
gave me the latitude to behave this way
in the Kennewick case I must also add
that there was great tolerance by the
Office of General Counsel and I think I
thank them for that
I also especially thank Dennis Stanford
who's right here the chairman of the
Department of Anthropology at the time
for having the fortitude to join me in
the Kennebec endeavor the book no bone
unturned is chronological in its format
integrating different investigative
projects in order to tell its main story
it accurately reflects how I work
balancing at any given moment about a
dozen different projects well when you
read a book and then you later on you go
and see a movie you compare them noting
that the movie how the movie script
differed from the from the actual book
well I wanted tonight reverse this
project process in the sense that I want
to take you back to a couple of the
events that are described in the book so
that you can see how closely jeff has
captured the actual scene by referencing
two chapters in his book one of them is
entitled building people and the other
one is called the probe I want to talk
about the Waco investigation and I must
tell you that in Jeff's first draft of
the Branch Davidian chapters it was much
more extensive than what is printed in
this presented in this final version his
descriptions of the scene or accurate
but he felt that it was necessary to
trim it back because it was so harsh I
have not to my knowledge seen any books
come out on waco probably because it's
simply too much death from destruction
Jeff strikes a balance that lets you
know what it was like without
overpowering the reader it occurred on
April 19th 1993 it was a culmination of
a 51-day standoff and the final day in
which the Mount Carmel compound went up
in flames I have held off now for 10
years to show these slides to an
audience which depict the role of a
forensic anthropologist and a mass
casualty effort such as Waco we hear a
lot about mesh mass casualties and I
think this is one of the best organized
and best-run ones that I've had
work with and I think it is a good
example as to how this how this all
takes place I think Jeff from my from my
times talking to him is intrigued as to
how someone can ignore the smells and
numb out the sights but you have a job
to do and you do it to the best of your
ability forensics is certainly not a
field for everyone when I looked at the
slides in order to pick some for this
evening I also wondered how someone can
compartmentalize and tuck away this kind
of experience but you have to your task
as a forensic scientist is to discover
and report the facts being objective
thorough and meticulous if I could have
the slides please
so I'd like to give a summary of a few
of the components of the the Waco
investigation it's not something that I
was alone in doing for one thing my
colleague Doug you blocker and some of
my other colleagues worked with us very
closely in this and when we're talking
about the discovery and analysis of
human remains in a situation like this
the contributions of the forensic
anthropologists can be broken down into
some major categories for one thing
we're going to be involved in locating
and recovering human remains second
we're going to do examinations and
inventory of the remains and we're going
to be involved in interpretation Agosta
logical data there are some key players
in this many of them not all shown in
this picture but you're going to hear
the name of Pam stone and Pam stone is
this young lady right here she was 25
years old at the time is this car a rule
hide now married but careiess and this
at the time and that's how she's
identified in the book also at the same
age both very young Pam now teaches has
it has her doctorate khari I'm pleased
to say works with me at the Smithsonian
she is one of the finest osteolysis I've
ever known this is dr. Pierre Juana he
was the head Emme of the Tarrant County
Medical Examiner this is dr. Joe dizzy
no he is an FBI special agent and also
forensic odontologist and in charge of
their DNA laboratory and this is max how
now with the FBI but working with the
Tarrant County Medical Examiner this is
what the if it'll go a little darker I'd
like that if we can if you can tone it
down so so I can see it just a little
better this is what the emmys office
looked like and so you have multiple
different stations where we would have
tables this is going to Pam and car a
working behind me the way that I work is
I'm essentially writing the reports as I
go in the sense that we're working on
remains and I will have someone on a
computer that I'm dictating to it works
very well especially if the person is
very trained they know the language
because we certainly have a language of
a unto ourselves and they're editing
while I'm speaking one of the key
players in this
a very important person in terms of all
the photographs that you're seeing
tonight with maybe just a couple
exceptions is natural history science
photographer chip Clark he's absolutely
one of the finest photographers i i've
known this was the first experience that
i had taken him into such a heavy-duty
forensic situation you're seeing chip
slides here as we go into this then and
i break it down the osteological
examination is going to focus on an
inventory an assessment of physical
characteristics assessment of trauma
identification sorting of commingled
remains and preliminary examination to
start I want to talk about this business
of sorting of commingled remains and
preliminary examination at the Waco
compound there were 88 individuals that
lost their lives eighty-three of these
individuals were examined
anthropologically forty-one of them were
positively identified at the time of our
examination either by dentition or
fingerprints or by looking at pre-mortem
x-rays pre-mortem post-mortem
comparisons of x-rays during the autopsy
process we also develop biological
profiles for the remaining 42
individuals which were then identified
between the physical examination
identified by DNA analysis by DNA typing
the remains were exceptionally and
exceptionally poor condition because the
fire burned for nearly three days
reaching temperatures are close to 2,000
degrees
it was nearly a cremation temperature
and if you compare that with a typical
house fire for instance the typical
house fire is going to reach maybe a
thousand to twelve hundred degrees many
of the bodies of the adults were armed
with weapons at the time of the recovery
the recovery process was hampered also
by the presence of a staggering and I
mean in the million-plus rounds a
staggering amount of an armament and
ordnance particularly in an area
referred to as the as the bunker or as
we knew it at the time the munitions
bunker the leader the compound was David
Koresh at the time and one of the things
that had that occurred is there was
speculation that he had been able to to
escape essentially had a miraculous
now in talking about the commingled
remains most of the commingle remains
came from an area that we referred to as
the bunker they were extensively damaged
they were in advanced stages of
decomposition they were thoroughly in
intermixed and it was impractical at the
site to separate the individual remains
or to estimate the total number of
individuals in this bunker area it
thoroughly burned but there were so many
rounds of ammunition that there were
places within this bunker that were
little literally waist-deep in terms of
ordnance some of it exploded some of it
not hand grenades bullets this long 50
caliber machine gun bullets thousands of
rounds of ammunition
closely associated body elements
replacing the body bags for sorting at
the morgue when we did this preliminary
assessment what we were doing is
essentially separating the remains and
matching them and as we would match them
we would provide this is preliminary
descriptions we would describe them as
far as age sex race and we were focusing
at that point during the our examination
on remains that were undergoing rapid
decomposition many of the burnt many of
the remains from this area on the higher
level within this bunker within the
munitions bunker were burned but as you
got deeper within all of this ordnance
as well as some individuals being
wrapped by blanket sir or under hundred
different types of clothing there was
less burning but advanced stages of
decomposition because it was such a
dangerous area to get in it took longer
to get those remains out and so they
were they were deteriorating quickly and
one of the things that we needed to do
is work rapidly with the FBI disaster
squad who had who had specialists there
that were interested in taking
fingerprints and footprints we would do
preliminary descriptions of clothing or
other objects associated remains prior
to cleaning in a detailed forensic
autopsy now in dealing with this what
Jeff describes as he describes the
garage of the medical examiner's office
this is where we were relegated to it
was not an air-conditioned facility this
is khari right here this is Pam she's
gonna be setting up her computer this is
me and what we were faced with were body
bags that would have three and four and
five individuals in them none of them
complete we began starting on them
working through it and we'd set it up
and what khari and I would do is go into
each bag and begin separating out
individuals and we'd begin to start
dictating to 2-pam as we'd make our
notes and then working closely with us
would be two of the FBI disaster squad
fingerprint specialists and they would
be for instance even on the children
they would be taking footprints and
because many of those children had not
ever even been off of that compound
there was absolute co-mingling in the
sense that you would have no individual
that was complete you would have
multiple individuals and for instance
you can see a shoe here a shoe here and
lower legs only I've got another person
that we're starting right here
represented by lower legs and this is
going to be Mount Carmel and the numbers
that I'm got in this bag or in theory
gonna be 67 68 and that one I can't read
but 65 66 so even from the field they
thought they were probably at least four
individuals represented there and we
would go through and begin working
across each of these bags and matching
trying to match up shoes trying to match
up clothes looking at the hair looking
at the fracture patterns in the bones
and trying to build them because it it
was not of any use for instance for the
FBI disaster squad to say this hand I
can identify by a fingerprint that this
is so-and-so is here it's not that's
useful but if that hand is out of its
context if it's only a single hand and
there's not there's not some
identification as to the remainder of
the individual then you're not going to
have that person properly identified in
relation to this all of these body bags
were filled with extensive ordnance in
the sense that you have for instance all
of these are unfired bullets some of
them were fired some of them were not
and we would have to separate those out
and we would begin working through it
and dictating exactly our different
observations there were gas masks this
is what's showing up right here if you
can go a little darker maybe it'll show
my gas masks right here associated with
these remains
and working with two of the FBI
fingerprint specialist trying to get IDs
well it became very complicated in the
sense that we soon had five bags that we
were sorting and starting with and then
pretty soon we had one going and another
one going and another one going and we
were building people as is described by
Jeff's book we were describing trauma in
the sense that this you'll see more
closely but as you look at this right
here this is a child's cranium and on
that child's cranium you've got a a
puncture a linear puncture that's
located right here in the forehead there
were the sad thing for us and for
certainly the two very capable young
assistants that I worked with is the
fact that this is the area that the
Branch Davidians chose to put the
children most of the children were put
in this in this munitions bunker and so
this is a baby's blanket for instance
with little designs and there were lots
of lots of signs of what was associated
with those children and we worked there
for several days days and then also
ended evenings sorting out individuals
so that they could be identified this is
a small child with a diaper right here
and what made this as Jeff referred to
in his his section perhaps so very real
to us is the fact that there were
videotapes of the children and since
many of these children had not been off
of the compound one of the things that I
and my assistants spend a great deal of
time doing was looking at the children
other videotapes of the children to see
what kinds of clothing that they were
wearing and we were able to match up
those and often that contributed to the
identification of a particulars and sad
thing for us to look at these pictures
and to see these kids and then find that
sweater the inventory is a very
important thing in this whole process in
the sense that we in it with a degree of
burning that you have with the type of
decomposition that you have you
ultimately need to track something that
is hard and in doing that you're keeping
track of the skeleton so for instance
this is going to be a small child this
is a
about a four year old child skeleton
here with a left arm in place and we're
still hunting at this point in time for
the right arm we need to know that
because that's how we're going to get
our established number of individuals
that are represented in terms of age sex
and ancestry and trauma this is where
you're working more directly with the
medical examiners in the sense that you
will go from table to table and in that
process you will come up and provide
information to them and to the FBI in
the sense that the FBI has a very
elaborate team that is compiling all of
the records on these individuals they're
trying to get from all over the country
from all over internationally from all
over they're trying to get any kind of
dental x-rays any types of medical
records any type of hard information
that this person is there and we can go
up to a given journey look at it and say
I think this looks like a black male
that's got arthritic changes look in
your records for somebody that's a 60 to
70 years old with those types of
features and what that will do is that
will narrow very quickly the range of
possibilities and allow you to go to the
next stage which is working towards the
positive identification as to who that
person is
you see for instance in terms of aging
one of the things that we would put a
lot of attention to is the dentition for
instance in these small children or
taking the lengths of the long bones
looking at long bone growth and matching
it up on the basis of that and that's
what khari is doing right there Jeff
happened without coordination happen to
mention 47c this is the youngest one
that was there this little little one is
about 24 weeks in terms of its its
gestational age you can see that this is
a an inch long scale right here this is
the thigh bones the femurs the tibia
these are little pelvic bones the UNAM
'its those are two of the bones of the
frontal the forehead
for example in looking at this
individual with extensive burning this
is the mid-face area and then looking at
the width of the nose looking at the
shape of the lower portion of the nose
here looking at it in terms of the the
side view the facial forward nough sin
this area came up on this individual
looked at what there was of the cranium
and said this is clearly going to
represent a black male and this
individual had a lot of arthritic
changes and we
able to get a very quick identification
based on even such burn bone from the
experience and from the developing
forensic database that we've been
working with and developing here at the
Smithsonian and the University of
Tennessee one of the things that would
be nice and rarely did you get but this
is an example is a complete cranium from
the stance of the more you have the more
you can tell and in looking at this
skull for instance here of a female one
of the things that I would look at and
we would pick this up in terms of our
measurements is that she has a
relatively flat face and a relatively
broad face and as I look at the cranium
the skull and a side view it's fairly
short from front to back and I don't
show you this view but it's fairly wide
so it's a it's a short round cranium
looking at these features I'm seeing
features in here and metrically that I
would describe as somebody that's got
some Native American ancestry and one of
the things that we said on this is look
for somebody that's got a Hispanic
ancestry and that's what this individual
turned out and that's one of the clues
that would help identify this person
there were eight definite gunshot wounds
trauma is a very important part of the
analysis it was very much a try and
figure out what individuals were dying
from and many of the individuals died
from from smoke inhalation carbon
monoxide poisoning but there were some
individuals that were clearly suicides
or shooting another individual within
the compound there were eight definite
gunshot wounds looking at this
individual here for instance this is an
individual where you've got right ribs
and there's a fracture pattern here this
individual was shot in the head also
shot in the in the right side of the
chest and extract from this area the
chest was a nine millimeter Chinese
bullet Chinese manufactured bullets
certainly not a one used by the any of
the federal people it was something that
was from internal within the compound
there was at the time certainly a great
deal of concern at Koresh was alive it
was it was reported and certainly rumors
were fast and furious that people had
seen him escape and so one of the one of
the high-pressure things was to try and
confirm the presence of this individual
yes or no and these remains here are
those that were actually identified as
Rep
that individual you have lower legs
burned away this is a head area right
here
arms are burned away and in relation to
this this is what's coming out at the
cranium it's severely fragmented by the
fire but more complicated than that in
the sense that as you would reconstruct
this one of the things that we would put
together one of the starting points is
of course always x-rays and in this
x-ray this is this is a radiographic
plate showing those particular fragments
and positioning it I think in my in my
career where I've worked on thousands of
bodies I think this is the most dramatic
x-ray that I have ever seen in my life
this is of that individual this is his
frontal right here the nasal area of the
maxilla and when I saw that when we
positioned that and I saw that on the
x-ray I thought oh I just cannot believe
it and this area right here is a gunshot
wound to the forehead this is putting
the skull back together one of the
things that anthropologists trained as
an animus are very good with their hands
some people are particularly good at it
Dave hunt in our whenever I need
something that's complicated really put
together I always turn it to Dave and
we're putting these back together you
can see the entrance wound right here
the question in part was timing to try
and figure out when this occurred when
the gunshot wound this is a frontal
wound Exodus we measure across it and
all of this we we prepare very detailed
descriptions it's the hard part of my
job is not the analysis that's actually
that's the challenge the hard part is
always then writing it and editing it
and that's why we try and write them as
we go so that we at least have a leg up
in terms of that process describing the
radiating fractures the LeFort line
fractures we had an experienced medical
illustrator with us this is looking at a
lateral view of the cranium as it's
partially put together we aren't gonna
get much further with that this is her
reconstruction of what it looked like in
terms of radiating fractures this is the
external exit here with external Beverly
this is where it's excellent exiting out
the back of the skull and this is
showing the burned area the charring
from the area that he was found at and
this is looking at a at a close-up one
of the things that was clear to me is
this this individual was was shot in the
forehead before the fire occurred
because you can see for instance that
this area here with with
Nicoll musculature which is quite quite
thick helps protect this area but all
the area that is charred is is still
fairly superficial and the only place
you go deep on it is where you have
exposed area that explode exposed
underlying cancellous bone or diplo
along the opening and so it was clear to
me that it was the fire came after this
individual and had perished at least in
terms of when it reached that particular
body in the initial raid he was shot and
there were some video tapes that showed
this one of the one of the scenes that
I'll always remember is it's when one of
these little children came up and jumped
on his lap and he he winced from that
this is looking at the femur here which
was injured by post-mortem shrapnel but
looking at the left hip bone the left
innominate and there was a projectile
that it entered from the outside and
passed through and through and looking
at it here in terms of what the bone
this is coming from the anterior pass
through the through the anterior portion
of the ilium right here and exited out
the the back side and this certainly was
becoming infected you could tell that by
the way the tissues were certainly
needed treatment for that would not have
been fatal but it it not with treatment
in relation to this this individual was
identified on the basis of the forensic
odontology team they had a very
experienced forensic odontology team the
dental records were in place for him and
that established an identification and
on top of that we were also able to
confirm the identification couple that
with an ante mortem post-mortem
radiographic comparison because he had a
type of fatigue fracture to the lower
spine that is referred to as a separate
neural arch or spondylolysis some of you
in here have that and that's a that's a
separation that occurs right in here
this is an anti mortem x-ray of this
individual and you can see the lumbar
vertebra you can see the neural spines
and we had this available through the
through the work of the FBI in terms of
tracking these records and then in
relation to that the spine was then
positioned in the same anatomical
position so that we could track out the
same sort of little shape of the
the vertebra the shape the individual
matchup these individual neural spines
and follow them as they as they get
larger or smaller their individual
features as well as matching up right in
here that's separate neural arch there's
no question in terms of the death of
that that individual one of the most
complicated things that we had to deal
with in as far as the individuals from
the bunker
was there was so much injury as a result
of all of the exploding munitions and in
relation to this you're looking at a
forearm area this is going to be almost
the beginning of a hand these are
bullets that you're seeing here there
are thousands of rounds of ammunition
that went off and the experience that I
had here in being able to recognize
gunshot wounds intentionally inflicted
gunshot wounds versus to those that are
lower velocity exploding ammunition that
actually came out to form a great
impression on me that that helped me
tremendously when I worked in Croatian
on various instances dealing with
individuals that died in the serb
croatian conflict and were victims of
shrapnel
explosions things like that so i learned
a lot that carried right over to to an
equally horrid scene you see for
instance bullets shell casings that are
mixed up in the tissues and there were
lots of shrapnel injuries in these
little children in the sense that here
for instance you're seeing the eye
orbits the frontal bone right here that
I showed you earlier when it was not so
clean this is the external view of the
forehead area the upper portion a
close-up of that fraction fracture and
an internal view with the internal
beveling it's an irregular piece of
metal that went through there and you
can follow us trajectory as it goes
right down into this Pinoy bone this is
part of a neural arch from that same
little child where you have an embedded
metallic fragment and one of the one of
the spinal spinal column bones this is
looking at a and a child it was about 15
months of age the skull has been
reconstructed you can see shrapnel
injury here shrapnel injury here also
right here right right there and
close-ups of these they're so different
in their character from from something
that would come out
an intensional gunshot wound they don't
have the same at least under these
circumstances of exploding munitions
don't have the same sort of impact to
puncture like a true a true gunshot
wound close-up of the temporal this is
the ear hole right here this is the
right mastoid process and you're seeing
this this penetrating defect right there
and this is an arm of that little 1 year
old and you see an embedded metallic
fragment right here with linear
fractures going up and down this is the
right humerus
well the compound looked like this at
the time of the siege and I want to take
you to this scene here that deals with a
section and Jeff's book referred to as
the probe now this area right here this
area right here is is the area that is
the was the bunker the munitions bunkers
we referred to it at the time that area
right there so many rounds of munitions
in there it is not any there were so
many places on this compound that you
could have gone underground where there
was no fire or anything like that and I
just cannot conceive that you would want
to go and put women and children in that
particular location I want to take you
to this location right here which is the
underground firearms range it is about
this is going to be the entrance right
here it's about 30 some feet across here
and in this length about a hundred feet
here it's below ground this is the
entrance going into it right here and in
relation to this the Texas Rangers were
having a hard time locating the remains
of the individuals that had died in the
initial raid and from informants it was
reported that they had been buried
buried in this underground for firearms
range under garbage and so this is what
the Rangers had been told and they and
they also brought in a cadaver dog which
is a dog that's specialized in in trying
to locate by scents and odors where
there are where they're buried remains
and that dog was having having no
success at all no success at all and you
had this Ranger they are digging holes
digging holes and all over and they just
can do it and so do dizzy no I asked me
if we would go in there and see if we
could help them out so as we're getting
ready to do this I'm talking to this
Texas Ranger and I say well what I need
is I need something that's a metal rod
that I can shape and I'm telling you
what I'm thinking of in my mind is I
have I specialize in probes in the sense
that I have a number of different probes
they have essentially a t-shaped they
have a ball expanded handle and what you
can do is you can press down and you can
feel the resistance of the soil and you
can tell whether it's disturbed or
undisturbed now that seems very
specialized and I can tell you that I've
actually published on this in some
international journals in terms of my
techniques and I can also tell you that
my my family as kidded me greatly for
being an internally internationally
renowned prober so so I mean they really
they get a big hoot out of this but this
is what I was trying to to think of in
my mind and tell this ring settled on
some rebar to to come up with that and
so this is doctor de Zeno here and I
asked him okay here's the garbage in the
in the this is going to be in the south
east corner southwest corner of this
bunker and there was a lot of garbage
that contained everything from haircuts
to to human waste and I could understand
easily in an area as muddy and mucky and
Slurpee as this is how a dog could
become very confused and what I asked
him to do as I said okay let's take and
move this back so I can so I can get
access to the ground and what I begin
doing with this metal bar that I've
shaped into a into a crook is I become
pushing it down and I'm feeling the
resistance of the soil and after I work
through that garbage I say they're not
there so in relation to that I then
begun working through the through the
mud and and ultimately settle on an area
on the opposite side that had a lot of
concrete it has a wheelbarrow some of
the things that Jeff's describes and I
say this is it and in relation to this
this is this this is the northwest
corner in relation to that what I'm
doing is I'm using the probe and I'm
starting with red flags to mark out what
the grave looks like in the sense that I
can tell disturbed from undisturbed and
I've now got it defined and this is the
area that we're going to go
dig and so we begin to open it up and as
we get down about a foot then I've got a
head coming out right here and we will
go on and ultimately they are wrapped up
in there's a lot of clothing there they
are wrapped up in either blankets or
sleeping bags you have four individuals
in this pit these were the the four
missing individuals that we were looking
for in terms of trying to to identify
the last unaccounted for remains from
the compound if ever there was such a
thing as as described in a Newsweek in
terms of this being a a scene of a
suicide involving self-inflicted gunshot
wounds and murder this this was the case
and I have not ever talked about that
but I the Branch Davidians certainly
those that were the adults not in the
bunker necessarily but they they were
heavily armed and there were certainly
in my opinion and no one's ever asked
really but as they were suicidal members
of the group that set the fire now if I
could go to the next set of slides now I
want to look at something that's a
little different a different kind of
project and I think this is really to
give you kind of a bipolar look at what
I really do and I have to say upfront
that this component is really
fascinating to me and it and it helps me
balance the other side I'd like to talk
about some of the work that I've been
involved in on early man studies early
man in the New World and in doing this I
want to point out that I asked some very
close colleagues in this process one of
them is is Dennis Stanford one of them
is Richard Jantsch and in all of this we
have a team approach and we've been
working for years very closely with the
University of Tennessee to develop a
very elaborate database it's focused
focused on developing elaborate database
is collecting osteological data for
numerous groups from different time
periods and geographical areas and I'm
I'm a North American in terms of this
research so when I say geographical
areas I'm talking about north
primarily from the western half of the
US and what we've developed is a
standardized recording format for dental
and bone inventories and for coding
pathological conditions and for taking
measurements of the cranium and the post
cranium and what this does is this
approach allows us to maximize our
comparability of data by facilitating
direct comparisons across samples and
what we have in the terms of the
skeletons that I've looked at in this
system for instance when we score bone
pathology we actually on a computer
tracked 1,500 different variables that
break down in in terms of major
categories of infections or trauma or
arthritic changes but we've entered data
now in four well over seven thousand
african-american euro-american at Native
American skeletons from North America
with especially extensive records for
the prehistoric and historic populations
the plains and Great Basin I'm from
Wyoming and so you'll never get the
plains out of me entirely and so so I a
lot of my basic research on those
populations now this database was
initiated for studying more recent
populations from the western half of
North America but it's breath is what
enables a very systematic analysis of
ancient remains either individually or
statistically within a comparative
framework now when you're talking about
ancient remains they're very rare in
North America you can count on your
fingers remember well-preserved
well dated skeletons in museums today
but all total I have examined about them
about the bones of about 25 individuals
some with nearly complete skeletons and
others being partial that are dated
older than 8,000 years and when I say
that I'm saying radiocarbon years in my
dates and in reality you can just take
in your calculation if I say 8 or 9 at
at least one or two thousand years and
that's what you're getting in terms of
calendar years so I've looked at about
25 that are older than 8,000 and
sometimes you'll hear me in talking
about this section I'll talk about is a
set of fossil remains that in the total
sample comprise ten thousand six hundred
to about seven seventy nine hundred
radiocarbon years and when I say
fossilized they're not truly fossilized
but but some are very heavily
mineralized and it's a way for me to
denote this series as being being
ancient in terms
North American prehistory well let's
look at just a few of these key
specimens one of these is this female
right here this is Minnesota woman she's
dated radiocarbon years 79 hundred years
she was found in 1931 by highway workers
who were digging a road bed with
machinery and they reported the find
immediately and dug the skeleton out and
kept it safe until until a professor at
the University of Minnesota Albert Jenks
could come and collect the remains it's
a very well preserved skeleton if you'll
focus it for me please she is a little
bit has a little bit of facial forward
that's right in here prognathism right
here another key specimen is this male
and this is also from Minnesota it's
also one of the first ones that was
found this is a male that's aged about
32 to 36 years he's known as Browns
valley and he was noticed by a layman
who was interested in archeology as
gravel was being unloaded in his
driveway in 1931 and this man a very
responsible citizen mr. Genest Jensen
picked up the bones out of the load he
rescued more bones that came out of the
second load and then he located the
probable source of the quarry and he
notified professor Jenks
of the fine and Jenks was able to
excavate the site the original site in
1934 and he found an additional tooth
that that fit this individual and he
found some more bone fragments all of
which fit the original discovery if
you'll focus that for me this burial was
covered by a single flat stone and the
pit was lined with red ochre and stone
tools including this this is a lateral
view of that skull and a bronze Valley
point one of these very narrow thin
types of points was associated with it
one of the most spectacular ones that
sometimes you you've read about in the
Washington Post or you've heard about is
this one here and this is the best
preserved of all this is the spirit cave
mummy and this is a male it's 42 for a
year for 40 to 44 years he was removed
from a cave
in 1940 he and his matte wrappings and
transferred to the Nevada State Museum
where it's been stored there for more
than half a century and it was crated up
but not not opened because they did have
an expert at the time look at it and in
looking at it that expert had thought
that these remains were probably a
couple thousand years old well just a
few years ago 1996 they they dated it
this some of the the fiber associated
with this is tule matting and found out
that this in radiocarbon years is ninety
four hundred and fifteen years this male
was wrapped in two large pieces of
diamond plated matting and covered with
a large open twined tule mat so this is
a thule mat here as you go underneath
that you're seeing this diamond plated
matting here is the head it's covering
the head there were actually two large
pieces one folded over and and so to
close in the head and the rest of it
covering up the rest of the body you're
seeing the head portion this is a spinal
column going down this is an exceedingly
rare type of fiber manufacture it is not
anything like occurs or has occurred in
Nevada for the last thousands of years
and one of the places that you do find
it occurring is in ancient textiles over
in Asia now in relation and Japan in
particular but as you're looking at this
you're looking at a lateral view here's
the jaw this is a jaw right here
here's his zygomatic arch this is a
close-up this of this diamond plated
matting this individuals legs were semi
flexed his clothing was come included a
well-constructed pair of moccasins with
a breach cloth of fiber the right
moccasin had patches on the toe and on
the heel as we look at him here you're
seeing the moccasins right here
incredible preservation for this time
period it's because the cave that he
came out of which is really a rock
shelter is about about 15 feet in terms
of his depth about 25 feet across and it
was buried
in there one of the things that he had
was a rabbit skin blanket what you're
seeing remnants of it right here looking
at the face this is from the intestinal
area this is a copper light right here
they were able to do detailed analyses
that would help determine what this
individual ate in terms of his last meal
and looking at a frontal view of the
skull the hair was analyzed forensically
and as a is a dark brown with reddish
reddish tones was probably darker
originally in life looking at a 3/4 view
this is a stereo lithographic model in
the sense that one of the things that we
do is we examine skulls and we do it in
terms of taking very specific
measurements on the cranium that
described the shape of the skull we are
able to we now we continue to advance
with the times and now we do it in terms
of 3d morphometry in the sense that we
take X Y Z coordinates but it's
describing the shape of the cranium and
in doing that we essentially capture the
dimensions of breaths like facial
breaths fault breaths we do length
facial forward Ness we also do Heights
and in working working and measuring a
specimen as well preserved as a spirit
cave mummy you cannot always see the
different landmarks so we we work very
carefully with those landmarks but also
in order to to get additional
information we CT scanned and you're
seeing a we took a CT scan cat scan of
the the cranium and then through a
polymer technique we produce this
accurate representation of what the
skull is like in terms of its size
that's a stereo lithographic model and
then we cast that and in the comparisons
that I'm going to show you as we go on
over the next few slides I'm going to be
using this cast and a lateral view of it
and you see it looks like a CT scan in
the sense that it's got this sort of
step plane type of topographic type of
appearance but it is accurate in terms
of its scale and size now looking at it
one of the areas that I want to focus on
is is as I mentioned we I'm interested
in questions about who these people were
and what their lives were like I'm not
interested
only and where they came from or who
they gave rise to there's a there's so
many different questions along the lines
of health and what life was like I
consider that a fascinating area of
study and for instance the injuries that
this individual had he had one of these
separate neural arches although it was a
unilateral one one of these fatigue
fractures are the back he had some
fractures to the hands he was recovering
at the time of his death from an impact
to the left side of the head temporal
this is that lateral view of that skull
you can see it's it's true in terms of
the shape and metrically it is and
looking out at the left temporal area as
we focus in you see the indentation
fracture right here with a radiating
fracture going up and radiating fracture
going down it is beginning to bridge he
was healing it was recovering from that
at the time we code this in in terms of
a computer and we get very detailed in
the sense that for instance we track the
fracture that fact the type of the shape
of the fracture this is blunt force
trauma whether it has radiating
fractures how severe it is
it measures six millimeters by six
millimeters the number of fractures
whether it's healing or in the stage of
healing netcode 2 and so we keep all of
that so that I can look at through the
inventories that I have whether it's
forensics or whether it's archeological
I can say exactly what we've seen and
then I can answer specifically how many
fractures we have how many distal thirds
of the ulna we have and how many defense
wounds that we that we have for instance
I'm surprised when I work with these
early ones that one of the things it was
a tenuous life back then as well and and
for instance if you talk about the males
in these small but in this early sample
50% of the males have skull fractures
that they're dealing that they've
experienced in their life this
individual here is a 17 year old from
the Grimes burial shelter also 9,000
plus years in age and this is his left
second rib and there's a cut to that rib
right there and a cut right there
this individual was stabbed and this is
looking it comes into the side this is
the internal view of that as they pulled
the blade out at pulls the fibers back
in the bone fibers back in as you look
at it you can see pieces of an embedded
obsidian still inside that so this is an
individual that died as a result of
violence over 9,000 years ago in
now one of the things that we do is we
characterize skulls in terms of their
shape and I led up to that in terms of
looking at the Branch Davidians and
saying you can do this in the sense that
what we have and this has grown
tremendously but what we have are
documented reference samples where we
work with populations we're not looking
at the skull and classifying the skull
on its own features but with experience
you you realize that there's variation
and you're able to do that but we
describe them metrically in terms of
their their different dimensions and we
establish different population reference
samples this is one of the studies that
we're doing right now in terms of our
English colonists that we're working
with in this sense that there are
English colonists have we've gotten
taller through time well one of the
things that's happened is in getting
taller
Balt height is increased that's a part
of it they're still English colonist and
they still look like Europeans but we're
tracking things like secular change and
monitoring these types of things and
when we work with different populations
you begin to see within a population
that absolutely there's variability but
there is also a specific constellation
of features that you see that you can
describe metrically and measure and for
instance as I look at this individual
right here I see this male these are
males with well-developed brow ridges
all of them and I see a relatively broad
face heavily built cheek bones heavily
built Mailer's a wide by zygomatic
breadth to cross here and as I look at
this individual I'd say this individual
also has a very heavy facial development
across here and then I compare this with
this individual right here and this
individual is of European ancestry
Europeans are noted for their very
prominent noses they're not as heavily
built in the mid face area as we look at
it and in the back you see a lot of
similarity recognizing that there's
variability but we can characterize in
terms of population means or centroids
what a population looks like and realize
what the variability is around that mean
and so if we looked at this individual
right here and we looked at this
individual here even without having much
training I could take some of my new
graduate students and I could say sort
these skulls out and give me the number
of groups and what they would do is they
would wind up saying well
this guy looks very different and these
two look a lot alike and I could take
this one and I get and we have been
analyzing a number of these I could
process with a very experienced team I
could process 50 of these skeletons and
measure 50 these skulls and I could slip
in six of these and they would go right
down the line and nobody would think
otherwise because they are so similar in
terms of their morphology now when I
look at this in a multivariate type of
representation if I take some of these
ancient skulls that I talked to you
about and I'm gonna we've done this with
larger numbers that we can get access to
but for instance Browns Valley is right
here Pelican Rapids which is Minnesota
woman is right here she's 15 and he's in
his 30s she's a kid basically she's an
she's a teenager and you're dealing with
sex differences but you control for sex
you you neutralize them in terms of
their their sex features in terms of
cranial morphology and you see that
although they necessarily didn't look
the same to you metrically how they
break out they're quite similar and
spirit cave is going in their same
direction now these are from Minnesota
and this is from Nevada and it's they're
not the same population but they show
the same general kinds of features now
this is comparing two world population
data and one of the things that you see
is Polynesians right here you see in
these yellow triangles these are
Americans American Indians I have nine
different groups and those groups would
include groups like the crow in the
Blackfeet and the and the Cheyenne are
in here the there are suin groups in
here a Ricker which is a northern plains
tribe we include all of these different
groups and one of the things that you
find is that they're here and this
particular one up here this is a
siberian group very similar and in
looking at this process basically what
we're doing is we're looking at or
creating hypotheses relating origins and
relationships through this type of
morphometric analysis and what allows us
to take this on as is the understanding
that cranial facial morphology is under
very strong genetic control and size and
shape provide a basis for tracing
biological affinity and for tracing
population historical relationships
through time and what this does is where
we're using statistical
approaches where we're taking a whole
bunch of different measurements where
we're looking at the relationships
between those variables and we're
comparing these fossils to metric
population data for say American Union
groups and other world populations so
I've got for instance Southwest specific
people here I've got Africans here I've
got Europeans are going to be these
triangles right in here and you're
basically asking the question do these
fossils in terms of their measurements
do they fall within the range of
variation of recent populations and if
so to which group are they most similar
and it is these comparisons that allow
us to look at historical links between
ancient crania and extant populations
historic populations we can then look at
relationships and hypothesize those
relationships and when we do this when
we take this multivariate statistical
approach and this particular comparison
is based on 25 of these different
measurements that I'm talking about is
that for one thing there's a lot of
variation you're capturing world
variation but you can break it down into
independent axis and this axis right
here explains 23 percent of the
variation in this world population
grouping of crania and this axis right
here explains some 19 percent of the
variation and on this first axis what
you see is that it separates the
Minnesota fossils right here and spirit
cave to some extent and what it's saying
they're most different from is they're
most different which is the other side
of the axis is they're most different
from Africans and they're most different
from Southwest specific populations and
what this axis is doing is it's really
highlighting the uniqueness of Browns
Valley and Pelican or Minnesota woman
relative to all modern populations and
what it's doing is you can actually look
at the variables that are contributing
to this and in particular the variables
that are most important in this are the
vault breath the base width here
the frontal flatness the nose width and
some of the facial forward mists that's
what's being displayed on this
particular axis here and what is telling
you is that Browns Valley and Minnesota
woman and to a lesser degree spirit cave
differ first off from all older all
world
Galatians but especially those from
African Southwest specific and where
their most different is they tend to be
whiter in the base they tend to have
much narrower noses they tend to have
flatter frontal bones and they tend to
project for they have upper facial
forward mists well what we found
interesting is that these Minnesota
fossils are also extreme on the second
axis this is this axis and so they're
down here
they're the extreme on this end and
Native Americans and the Siberian group
which is essentially very similar to
Native American is is is is where the
separation occurs and this axis reflects
variation in face heights so what's
happening is that you've got a
separation on the basis of nasal height
orbit height and mid facial Heights and
if you want to simplify all of this in
terms of how it breaks down you'd say
well for one thing these early ones can
be characterized by having low faces or
in our language short faces from this
landmark nazy onto here it's a short
face and if you look at the cranium it
is a long narrow cranium in contrast an
American Indian cranium which is the
other the yellow triangles the other end
of that spectrum that is going to be
characterized by a broad face and a long
face and a short broad cranium if I can
have the lights please
so for instance if I wanna pick out a
Northern Plains Indian skull and
characterize it as an example as I look
at this frame then completely this
landmark right here Maisie on this map
right here across why did this
population among the whole population is
going people on face in the same sample
this is a head color for the maxilla
right here and the mayor is going to be
a wider face thank you can be a white
face and a much stronger hucklebuck your
space
applause ears you take that long broad
face and combine that with a short blank
maximum length broad crane that's one
way of putting a skull there
here's another example this individuals
with older blocks feet so top track by
the terms of facial length but my
graduate students can see it you can see
it and we can they certainly can explain
it in terms of their Asian population
creation it's going to measure out the
long face
that's a wide heavily built face with a
short broad crane now
I could pick up this stall which is one
I showed you and we could move 15 these
down the line where you've got an expert
digitizer measuring measuring measuring
and you put this right in and they'd
never say a word because it's got broad
face heavily built and it's a short
broad crane if you look at the mail it
looks like this you pick up the female
the female is not going to have the sex
features males tend to have high
vertical forehead let me say it again
females tend to have high vertical
foreheads and very little brow develop
development depending on whichever
population you're talking about where is
it so this is a female whereas males
tend to get more of a slope therefore it
they tend to get their hours with them
this is a short broad cranium heavily
built face this is a male this is a
female and you could run this down the
line
would not pick it up this individual is
from Mongolia so is this person same
stance there this is part of our
Mongolian surgery from Mongolia Tibet
from Siberia you can identify these
types of features and these are the
kinds of features that you can identify
in Plains Indians or other Native
American groups now you take somebody
like spirit cave and we take this cast
that you've seen pictures oh look at
this this skull is put together totally
different it's going to be in terms of
measurements for one thing it is a very
large cranium
Native Americans in terms of their
features if you look at world population
variability one of the things the
constellation in size is the
don't phase an average-size praying a
wall when you deal with these skeletons
that are 8,000 years older what they
tend to be is a much more average size
based a smaller face but a very large
cranium they often have very small post
cranial skeleton very large necks and I
haven't I'm intrigued by them but if you
look at the face it tends to be now
compressed a short face it's not it's
heavily built but not as heavily built
by any stretch fairly narrow in here and
it's a long narrow cranium
now you're an archaeologist out there
that once in a while help support and
you get a phone call in the coroner says
you need to go out and check out they
found out some phones they found some
phones washing out of the river and you
go out there and they start picking up
bones and that particular person happens
to look like this well this is an
archaeologist that he's dealt with
Native American bones and he's down
there with some pioneers and he doesn't
know exactly what he asked but he looks
at this he said well alright there's
some developing on this face but this is
obviously not a heavily built place and
it tends to be kind of long well I think
this is gee I got two choices
if I live in Washington it's either
gonna be Native American or it's some
sort of European pioneer and he thinks
well and then it gets another person
looking after they say oh I think this
person is European and that sets off a
controversy that you have not no wait
because when he sent this individual out
to the analyzed radio cut arena carbon
dating it comes out encounter years
ninety six hundred years and this guy
has got a at level a spear point
embedded in area and where we were
contacted is the corner was a dilemma he
had a real problem he could not believe
what he was seeing as far as reports and
we were contacted at the Smithsonian and
asked to consult on this because we have
been working on individuals that look
like this and so we had some thoughts
and what we had worked out initially was
that the remains were going to be flown
here to the Smithsonian the director's
office of this museum had and was
willing to provide an escort to fly this
app corner there's going to be a
coroner's representative come out and it
was going to be formally analyzed here
at Natural History with specialists like
dr. chance and others coming in to work
on it here well before that happened
everything blew up that Eliza
before that happened everything blew up
in the sense that that it was the Corps
of Engineers when they realized how old
it was decided that they had to reclaim
the specimen they pulled it away from
the coroner before the archeological
report or the the coroner's report was
finished and they set it on a fast track
in order to have these remains were
buried without any scientific study you
can count on your fingers the number of
skeletons that exists like this it is so
well preserved I am of the eighth plane
of scientists I'm the only one that's
seen it it has not been it has been
studied by government representatives
but it has not been formally studied by
some very experienced scientist that
have been waiting six years to do this
this is what Jeff's story is about is
the is the SOG I'm going to try and and
examine the Kennewick Man skeleton it is
not a simple skeleton that stands alone
in the sense that for one thing in the
hey story very important collections
we've seen very important specimens such
as Pelican Rapids Minnesota woman that I
showed you be reburied and Browns Valley
and many others such that there has been
such a history very ancient remains that
there are so many unanswered questions
that if we don't have the opportunity to
study these we will never know the
answers to who the people the first
people were in the knurl new world or
where they came from it's not that I
needed another skeleton to look at it's
just simply that if I coming from the
Smithsonian could not get access to a
skeleton as important as this then I
felt that some assistant professor or
some graduate student working on his
dissertation that needed the study this
would never have a chance
and so we Dennis and I and others stood
up for what we felt was the public's
right to this information that no one
owns the past and that we need to be
free to study things that are found for
one thing if you just automatically find
on federal land not just poor of
engineer but federal land have a policy
that something is found and it's
immediately reburied without having
people that really know what they're
doing look at it you might have a 20
year old forensic case where somebody's
been looking for someone for that long
and the bones are found and they look
well okay let's give it to somebody and
ribéry it well you can't have this and
when we do this type of morphometric
analysis that I was laying out here one
of the interesting things that we find
is that when we examine these ancient
ones relative to modern populations one
of the things that they show is features
most like Europeans or Polynesians or a
group called the I knew much more so
than to current American Indians and I
want to show you something that that
that just by first saw it it blew me
away this is if you'd focus it for me
please this is spirit cave that you've
been looking at right here and this
right here is upper cave chukoti n that
is an Upper Paleolithic fossil it is it
is from China and it's dating is not
quite clear but it's at least or thought
to be as old as 24 to 29 thousand years
look at the similarity in terms of the
morphology just looking at them now this
is much older and it's much more robust
than than what spirit cave is but if you
put them in this type of metric analysis
and classify it one of the amazing
things is this guy classifies here on
the space and this guy classifieds there
in the space they are so similar and yet
they come from two different continents
and are separated by thousands of years
this guy here spirit cave 9400 from from
Nevada is closer to him in terms of his
morphology than he is to any
contemporary Native American group or
historic Native American group found in
the same country
now as you begin asking questions as to
who these people are and where they come
from one of the things that I think you
can do in terms of upper cave is you can
follow them from the 20,000 years ago to
to 12,000 years ago when we recognize
them for instance along the per
circum-pacific area of Japan for
instance we can recognize them as a
culture called Joe Mon culture which we
can follow Joe Mon it's a Mesolithic
hunting-and-gathering population coastal
populations that are along the coast of
Japan for instance and they give rise
historically to a group known as the I
knew it is the aboriginal population
Japan
the president they Japanese that you
think of when you think of as Japanese
came in about two thousand years ago
with rice agriculture and metal tools
and they replaced largely the pre the
the previous people look at spirit cave
and this I knew cranium this is a
historic I knew cranium look at it in a
side view they're not identically but
what you find if you ask the question
who is spirit cave most like one of the
things that you've come to with these
early ones is they're not like anybody
they're absolutely different from us or
not modern they're different but if you
force the question and say oh I really
got to know whose it most like you'd say
it's like and I knew and second you'd
say it's like a European look at the
backside and I knew if I that particular
I knew you notice doesn't have a
mandible but if I wanted to find the
great mandible to put on it
I'd put spirit caves mandible on
this is what an I knew looks like
another one historic period another one
so what I've found through this research
with my colleagues is that there's a
fundamental difference in the basic
shape of the skull how it's put together
in these ancient ones in the sense that
the first Americans are very different
from later American Indians the American
Indians that that we recognize are very
similar to Mongoloids that we would
identify as people from Siberia from
Mongolia from from Tibet that those are
that's been recognized for a long time
and they have the features of a very
heavily built face well for decades we
have referred to the first Americans as
paler Indians and that is a designation
linked to the belief that biologically
they were related to the North East
Asians and were directly ancestral to
the modern Native Americans but I think
in reality the term paleo American is a
better designation for this ancient
population because available evidence
indicates that there are multiple
migrations of pre and post Clovis which
is a well known archaeological tool
assemblage pre and post Clovis of 13,000
years ago arrivals involving diverse
populations I think that's a much more
accurate assessment for the events in
the people in the new world and whether
individual skeletons such as spirit cave
or Kennewick are directly related to
later peoples is definitely yet to be
learned there may be early migrants that
have been replaced with competition such
that the tough guy gets the high ground
as Dennis says Dennis Stanford or change
your gene flow but I can tell you one
thing you will read in the paper you'll
see these people out there that will say
oh there's a change through time in
environments where one gives rise to the
other I do not buy that because for one
thing the people of spirit cave we're
eating rabbits and the people of 400
years ago we're eating rabbits and
eating rabbits is not a change there's
no change there that it's going to
change one into another and in the same
sense when you work across all of these
populations like we do what you find is
that beginning about seven
thousand years ago you begin recognizing
populations where you pick it up and
you'd say that's definitely an Indian
it's got all of those features that I've
talked about and so you see a very heavy
movement of populations and there may be
replacement there may be gene flow but
the bottom line is is that we have to be
free to examine those types of remains
and protect those remains for another
generation that has better techniques
and better better scientific methodology
than we do and if we lose all of these
irreplaceable specimens now we will
never have answers to the Past so I
thank you for your patience I would
invite Jeff we will we'll stop right
there and hopefully I haven't gone too
long thank you
you could raise your hand and we'll call
him out and Doug will answer him the
question was where does the kid stand
legally today in September of last year
a federal judge in Portland after six
years of litigation ruled essentially in
favor of the scientists he issued a
judgment against the government saying
that they had essentially violated or
ignored the federal rules in the law and
he ordered the scientist to produce a
study plan in 45 days which would have
been able them to do the study of
Kennewick Man
however as that was unfolding the
government appealed the the judge's
ruling as did some of the tribes and so
there is now an appeal in the Ninth
Circuit in California briefs were filed
by the government just within the last
two weeks the scientists will file their
briefs within the next week and it's
anticipated that sometime by the end of
the summer there'll be a hearing in the
Ninth Circuit on on the case one thing
that I'll point out that's very
interesting in the government's appeal
the one thing they only appealed on one
issue and there was a multitude of
issues they could have challenged they
conceded an enormous thing in their
appeal they conceded that these remains
are not culturally affiliated with the
tribes who are involved now in the
lawsuit that's an enormous concession to
make because they litigated the opposite
view for six years but on the appeal
they have not gone there
the only issue they're challenging now
is the definition of Native American in
the statute and what they're advocating
in their appeal is that these remains
now go to the Interior Department and
not be repatriated to anybody but that
they are defined as unclaimed which is
really a major change
from where they were in six years of the
lawsuit getting to the point that we're
at the government has spent well over
three million dollars in trying to block
the scientific study of the skeleton and
they have had in the and the plaintiffs
in this case are very pleased with it
they have had some experts look at this
in terms of doing an analysis what we're
holding out for is for the plaintiffs to
also have the right to study this
skeleton because for instance it has not
been digitized in this three-dimensional
morphometry the types of comparative
data that I have access to and Richard
Jan's for instance has not been brought
to bear on these types of comparisons
there's so much that we can do in terms
of this very experienced team to to work
on it and and again it's not that I need
another thing to write up but it's just
that if we can prohibit the government
from saying you get to study this but
you we don't like your politics or
whatever you can't study this you know
then that's we can't allow that it needs
to be open to to scientific study it
needs to have peer review the
government's examination we welcome it
but it also needs a proper portion the
the correct thing in science is to have
peer review and have multiple different
investigators on such an important
skeleton let me just add one thing to to
that that was intriguing to me as a
reporter as I looked at the numbers and
the government had used over 25 lawyers
a cadre of experts and scientists on
this case these got and spent three
million dollars of taxpayer money these
guys use two lawyers who between them
spent eight thousand hours in six years
and charged them nothing
and I thought as a writer that was
compelling to me because it was the
David Goliath aspect of this whole story
and Doug he doesn't like me to say this
but Doug was the driving force to the
lawsuit there's an interesting scene
where Doug in his what was to become his
lawyer are going through the pros and
cons of whether to take this on and a
lawyer pointed out that as a scientist
going into the litigation against the
United States government is going to
turn your life upside down and it did
what they want we still need to be able
to study that skeleton well you're
looking at me the question was what do
you what do we think motivated the Army
Corps of Engineers to bury the site Doug
didn't mention that nor denied my
comment but essentially after the
skeleton was discovered and litigation
was filed and pending the Corps hired an
outside contractor and they buried the
site where the skeleton was found and
already bury it but they planted a
Russian olive trees and put a bunch of
rocks and boulders there so that the
site could never be investigated by
archaeologists why they did that my
sense is that this was clearly a
situation where the government had
literally just ignored some very basic
rules of law and they knew that Congress
was literally on the verge of passing a
law to prevent them from doing that it
had already been debated and it was a
formality to pass it and before they
passed it the government did this and I
think it was partly not so much a
scandalous thing as it is you see the
arrogance sometimes of government in the
disregard and this was one of those
cases where this became I think contest
between a few people who were
controlling really history for for all
of us and
I don't think there was someone who you
know got paid off to tell him to go do
this I think that it was just some
arrogance and you're never gonna get to
that site now I don't know if Doug has
another view of it well I'd say there's
compelling reasons to get to that site
in the sense that for one thing not all
of the skeleton was recovered or there
may may have been others or there might
have been cultural materials associated
with it that would help with the
examination of this individual you had
someone out there in the Oregon
government helping you write a
congressman yes yes absolutely there
there are problems he's pointing out
that we had interested congressmen in
trying to ensure the study of this and
the core is never paid any attention to
them that's I've been fascinated by that
but but
that was a predicate to the litigation
actually that the when the Congress and
the senators could even get the core to
put the brakes on and just slow down it
became very clear that there were no
other alternatives but litigation if
they were going to preserve the skeleton
it really was the last option you mean
from the Kennewick Man there were the
femurs from the Kennewick man
disappeared after the court had custody
of them and it became the subject of an
FBI investigation it was estimated that
they were valued at 25 million dollars
on the black market and ironically those
bones showed up the day after the
lawsuit was argued before the judge and
they showed up in the coroner's office
in a box and funny thing is the FBI has
searched and a search had been done of
that office and those bones were
apparently not there a couple years
earlier I don't try to explain how they
got there in the book because I
interviewed the FBI and the coroner and
everyone else who handled them and
everybody had a different explanation
for what happened and I that's a mystery
to me
how they got there but they're there now
you're talking about that Amy and how do
those skulls we laid if it all went on
the moments that have been found in
western China they I guess her skin her
skin about Europeans
yes he's talking about along them along
the Silk Road and those are much later
and those are certainly Europeans that
are associated with that when you're
looking at for instance someone like
this cast as a cast that was made by Jim
chatters who is the archeologist that
was called out by the coroner and this
is of Kennewick Man it's not accurate in
the terms of us being able to measure it
and and use it but it does show the
features and it shows
for instance the shorter face and the
long long narrow cranium when you
classify him using the measurements that
we can get he would go into this Pacific
I new type of cast Polynesian
Polynesians share these same features we
have I new are exceedingly rare we have
one at this Museum and it is an i new
female and i brought it to show you and
you can see just exactly what i'm
talking about it's a much more delicate
because it's a female that her little
short face right here and a relatively
long narrow cranium
I brought also just to show you this is
upper cave 250 nm you see how it's much
more robust much larger but these two
are such a match and I think you can
track this line all the way down for
thousands of years to the modern day I
knew and I think that those Joe Mon
hunting-and-gathering type people were
also some of the very first people to
get into the New World
one of the things that I'd also like to
point out is that museums have been
working very closely with tribes and
I've worked on many instances with
different tribal groups the with the the
Cheyenne for instance and and with a
crow and in helping get remains that do
belong to these different groups give
them the option of repatriation if they
decide that that's what they want to do
museums such as this as this one have
been working very closely with them to
try and ensure that NAGPRA which is it a
lot the law that is involved is is
responsibly done and when you're working
with tribes many not all but many often
are very interested in making sure that
the remains that they receive clearly
can be linked to their group the problem
is is NAGPRA
well-intentioned that it is is when you
start getting a thousand years old or
five thousand years older you get it
back into the Kennebec it becomes very
difficult without careful study to track
these relationships and sometimes their
relationships get so lost and confused
that you can't honestly do that and it
is my feeling that you know there is
such a written in these bones it's such
a legacy these people are gone to us but
if we have the right the opportunity to
learn from them that is their story that
they can convey to us and I think that
that's just a very powerful message that
we need to take time and listen to and
that's that's where I hope that you know
as things work out eventually you know
these aren't more adversarial
relationships but it's clear that you
need to have a pole that stands up for
something if you've got a pole saying we
will take anything and everything and
this is ten thousand years old it
absolutely has to be us you need to have
that other pole that says now wait a
minute we need to think about this
because this is this is the American
public's heritage too they have a right
the pass belongs to everybody we have
time for one more question
yes
yes chance
and the curator there told me that she
loved it you have
which the first owners
disappearing pests
all right let me she's asking about
Darnell's chance which is a historic
site occupied in the 1700s in Maryland
it's a very important estate it says
state property and they have a large
underground vault tomb that they didn't
know they had then all of a sudden there
it was and there were there are nine
skeletons in those they fit into my
colonial research another site of my
life existences is we're working on some
of the most important skeletons that I
think have ever come out of North
America from Jamestown from st. Mary's
City and one of the things that we want
to do in a few years we're coming up on
the the 400th anniversary of Jamestown
and we want to have and we're working
awfully hard to pull this off so you
have to encourage our new director to
say this is a good idea we we have been
analyzing it was always my dream to
analyze the folks of the 17th century
and to see they're all these little
glimpses of all they died from the flux
and they died from you know the
seasoning and what that really means so
we started working with st. Mary's City
and from st. Mary City we got
individuals the first time the best
skeletal series to come out of the last
half of the 1600s that would include the
royal governor first royal governor Lord
Copley and his wife the Calvert's and
the lead coffins that sort of thing that
gave me the last half the 17th century
and from Jamestown we've been excavating
over the last couple of years we've been
working in the the so-called third Ridge
or starving time cemetery and we've
excavated now a sample that gives me the
first half and I want to tell with my
graduate students and with this museum I
want to host a major scientific
symposium here the year before the 400th
anniversary where we tell a story as
it's written in those bones and also
couple that with an exhibition that
looks at this only the way that natural
history can do and so we want to do that
here and I want you to come for that and
Darnell's chance is a part of that now
where it's I need also see I'm a
comparative person and so I need to set
the 1600's but I want to go into the
seventeen hundreds of which Darnell's
chance figures into that Darnell's
chance has some it's exceedingly
important skeletons one of them I want
to talk to the family about putting on
display it is once in a while you'll
feel a skeleton where you just you
the pain of the family and there's a
little little kid in there that's about
a 12 year old that had tuberculosis
spinal tuberculosis pots disease and
that kid was a sicker than sick and and
it got the better of him but in relation
to that some of the worst dental
abscesses in pathology and I can just
feel the pain that that family
experienced in trying to give that
little kid that wasn't eating give him
anything sweet get him to eat anything
tearing the mouth up but tuberculosis
was a major problem coming out of what
we're seeing in these skeletons and I'd
like to show that as an example of how
serious that was now she's asking the
question can we differentiate and only
in the last few years one of the things
that we've come to realize is that you
can go into a colonial cemetery from the
17th century Jamestown for instance and
you can analyze the burials and I can
look at what these people are eating by
their bone chemistry and I can tell you
from the bone chemistry who was born in
England and came over here and promptly
died who was born in America and grew up
that first generation of becoming
American and who was like the Calvert's
raised over there came over here lived
for 20 years their bone chemistry signal
is not purely English and it's not
purely American there in between because
bone remodels now we have used that
technique on Darnell's chance and we've
also tried DNA now unfortunately the DNA
on those the the living descendants that
we want to compare with unfortunately
has not a unique type of DNA it's a very
common type of DNA so it doesn't help me
get it specific there but we applied
this bone chemistry signal and one of
the things and we have not reported this
anywhere but two of the this is Latisse
Lee who was thought to be the older
woman and in relation to that one of the
husband's was American born and raised
two of the husband's were born in
Scotland we thought the husband that was
going to be in this tomb was going to be
the middle husband who was very
important doctor who was involved in in
smallpox inoculations he was the
variolation process before what we do is
smallpox today and he was born in
Scotland so I tested his teeth I tested
his bone his bone tells me he's got an
American signature his teeth which tell
you where he grows up tells me he's an
American so the two husbands that are
Scottish born
cannot be either one of those the other
guy dies years after the Latisse Li does
so I honestly don't know who's in that
tomb right now
one more question
the Ainu are definitely an Asian
population but the way this in a
nutshell the way this works in my my
experience is you've got an African
origin of upper paleolithic anatomically
modern man those people smartest things
going they go blitzing into asia
they go blitzing into europe when you
look at these very early ones across
those first people to get in there and
you compare you notice I said spirit
cave for instance these most like the I
knew but you also see European early
like Norse in there that's because
they're coming into that same very
ancestral stock and then later on you
get this rapid radiation of Asian
northern Asian faces going along with
the rice agriculture they look for years
they thought they were European there
there are a descendant of an Upper
Paleolithic Asian population I don't
think of them as European they don't
they look at in some ways but they're
also very Asian and Asian in terms of
their genetics
his problem being from the Native
Americans and other food still what they
happened to miss tuffsy already in feet
of a demo sanitize that particular sort
of errands I don't I don't really know
what motivated the people because one
thing we haven't been able to determine
with any certainty is who actually made
the call there was an attempt in the
lawsuit to discern that through a
discovery and that was never determined
as who actually made the decision who is
the decision maker
we know who buried it but we don't know
who who called it so it's it's at best
speculation for any of us including
myself to to know with any certainty
what the what the motive was
you could be as right as as my guess was
ladies and gentlemen dr. oz Lee and mr.
Benton will be signing books in the
lobby thank you very much for joining us
this evening
Jeff Benedict is author of no bone
unturned it's published by HarperCollins
on the web at HarperCollins dot-com
you're watching book TV 48 hours of
nonfiction books all weekend ever